in rural maryland the unlikely
combination of axe throwing and strong
beer
we are an hour from washington but this
is a very different place donald trump
has many
ardent supporters here who think the
impeachment trial has made america
even more divided we got to start with
congress because they're the one who's
dividing us
there if you've got democrats and
republicans they're fighting all the
time so that gives us
the american people say okay it's okay
to fight according to the man who runs
this brewery
events like this are an opportunity to
bring together people
divided by politics it's very divided i
mean
and it's obvious too but we try to be
very civil i mean that's part of the
whole democracy thing is you want to be
able to talk to each other
you see the people in washington doing
you know fighting back and forth to each
other and that's not what we want here
we want to have a spot that's safe so
people can discuss
things they want to talk about and be
able to reach across the island
understand where they're coming from
but the truth is that across america the
rancor of the past few months
has not disappeared and the wound hasn't
healed
this is a fiercely republican enclave in
a historically
democrat state now the people here try
to put their political differences
aside but push them and you will get an
argument
it's like a microcosm of this profoundly
divided nation
down the road we visit chesapeake beach
a little more urban a little more
democrat
the ice is melting the opinions are
still sharp
i am hungry and we all are
and a lot of people that we talk to are
very upset about it
but you know it's it's another one of
those uh
disappointments that happened in the
past four years
during his presidency and everything
that he did
um was a joke i love mr trump
why what what do you like about it
because he changed america for the
better
america first and it was america first
no politics
well that's why they hated him because
he wasn't a politician he wasn't one of
them
so that's why they've all ganged up i
feel like on them
if the point of the impeachment trial
was to bring a full stop
it hasn't worked america is still a
nation where politics come
laced with mistrust adam parsons sky
news calvert county maryland